arrivant nos époques jorge semprun
quel beau dimanche quel beau livre aussi
un livre de la vive la mémoire
douloureuse un livre de la mémoire
je tire à la fois solitaire et solidaire
est ce parce que votre corps a été
enfermé dans un camp de concentration et
que votre esprit a été enfermé dans une
dune penser que vous récusez aujourd'hui
que vous refusez justement de d'enfermer
le récit dans la chronologie qu'au
contraire vous laisser vagabonder votre
mémoire
non je peux peut-être n'en sais rien
mais en tout cas c'est parce que parce
que je veux raconter autrement ans à la
reconquête de 2,2 ma liberté passe à
travers la reconquête la liberté d'une
et moi et donc une mémoire n'est jamais
chronologique mémoire se construit en
spirale il faut donc suivre cette
indication là je ne peux pas faire
autrement
si j'arrivais un roman disons tout à
fait de fiction je ne pourrais peut-être
pas du tout cette méthode nato de
recherche en fait bon vous étiez donc à
buchenwald et qu'il faut expliquer petit
peu votre situation vous dites vous même
moment que si tant est qu'on puisse le
dire vous étiez une sorte de privilégier
la barre une sorte indiscutable quoi
qu'il faut et fossiles comprendre parce
que c'est très difficile de résumer mais
attendez mais il faut aussi comprendre
un peu comment se passe le système
concentrationnaire nazi et dans ce
système là chaque chaque camp est un cas
particulier a une histoire particulière
à buchenwald 5 en particulier pour les
raisons très simples
d'abord parce que la densité de
politique allemand qui a été concentrée
et plus grande qu'ailleurs et qu'ensuite
le système disons deux usines de guerre
construits autour du camp a été plus
important que dans d'autres camps et que
donc c'est devenu un camp de travail
très vite et pas un camp d'extermination
et pour gérer un camp de travail où il y
a en moyenne cinquante mille personnes
qui travaillent et les commandes aux
extérieurs font encore cent vingt mille
personnes c'est à peu près 200 mille
personnes qui se tendent ministre et qui
travaillent dans les droits communs les
criminels de droit commun ne sont pas à
la hauteur et donc les communistes et
les socialistes allemands mais surtout
les communistes qui étaient en majorité
ont pris le pouvoir interne
d'administration pop up
ils ont éliminé le droit commun pendant
longue bataille et quand nous arrivons
nous les résistants et déportés d'autres
pays et vous rayonnez 1,39 et nous
communistes en 42 43 et à ces structures
d'accueil existent et le pouvoir interne
est entre les mains des déportés parce
que les 16 ministres de très près mais
sans pénétrer dans le camp il faut
imaginer qu'il ya c'est quand une
personne c'est une ville et cette ville
est entourée de barbelés électrifiés des
miradors les ss n'y entre pas une
administration inter interne et donc
alors vous vous étiez un communiste
espagnol donc vous avez une certaine
manière privée le sol communiste
espagnole qui parlait à la maman et donc
j'ai été placée dans un bureau du camp
bourg
pour ministre pour travailler à
l'administration de la main d'oeuvre nos
placements ci qui permettait d'agir
d'une certaine façon sur le sabotage sur
la préservation d'un certain nombre de
personnes dont préservation par exemple
de monsieur dassault de marcel dassault
oui exactement il a été sa vie a été
sauvée grâce à cette organisation
exactement bon alors quel beau dimanche
c'est évidemment un titre de dérision
il faut dire que vous racontez donc une
journée c'est un dimanche à boire une
valve qui commence cinq heures du matin
avec la neige qui tombe dans les
projecteurs et qui se termine le soir
autour d'un ragoût de chiens mais
fatalement quand on raconte une journée
dans un camp on pense immédiatement à ou
des chefs-d'oeuvre de sogeti 10 à dire
une journée d'ivan denissovitch cc voulu
bien évidemment c'est tellement voulu
que ce livre est écrit à gauche de ce
génocide en 45 ans 30 beaucoup de vent
j'ai décidé 21 ans à peu près décidé
qu'il fallait oublier parce que sinon la
vie serait un peu un peu embêtante
je n'ai pas du tout envie d'être un
survivant alors j'ai complètement oublié
et beau en soixante 60 61 j'ai commencé
à me souvenir de nouveau parce que les
circonstances de ma vie politique
espagnole à l'époque ont fait que je
tombe sur des gens qui racontaient des
souvenirs des digues du camp des camps
les leurs et qui me paraissaient de
souvenirs mal foutu c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait raconter et du coup j'ai
écrit un livre s'appelle le grand voyage
ce livre a été ces livres étaient
imprimés et à lettre publiée en 63 au
mois d'avril mais au moment où j'ai lu
une journée d'ivan denissovitch qui en
fait sur le plan de l'information ne
m'apprenez rien parce que depuis
longtemps mais en tout cas pour moi
personnel à ma propre biographie depuis
le 20e congrès on savait à peu près ce
que le stalinisme avait été mais le fait
que cette information m'arrive de
nouveau brutalement à travers l'airplay
récit d'un déporté de notre camp de
l'autre système et à travers en plus des
personnages dont certains avaient été
avec moi à bonneval parce qu'il ya un
personnage principal du l'âge de la
journée du banc de nice éric ce qui est
un ancien déporté de buchenwald qui sort
de bourlens pour aller là-bas ça c'était
c'était le choc c'est à dire que je me
suis sentie dès ce moment là je senti
qu'il fallait écrire ce livre
or vivre l'expérience qui n'était plus
une expérience innocentes ne joue pas
les seuls déportés nous nions pas les
seules victimes innocentes et avait
d'autres étaient c'était encore pire
parce qu'ils étaient victimes le régime
qui prétendait fanatiquement abolir donc
les âges
vous dites finalement ce que vont
devenir le plupart de ces gens des
camarades qui sont avec vous alors
certains sa femme ont effectivement être
victimes d'autres certains sont
répandues comme joseph rang musée
régional adjoint du parti qui était un
de mes quart de travail à buchenwald
d'autres vont devenir policier alors
sous d'autres deviennent dès lors il
était victime
ils vont devenir bourreau les centres en
religion sans transition s'est déporté
ces communistes allemands dont je parle
qui était d'ailleurs dans le cac avait
dans le camp rôle important et une telle
attitude disons pour simplifier positive
sans transition sont passés de la
bureaucratie communiste du camp à la
police de la zone d'occupation
soviétique en allemagne et après l'un
d'entre eux mêmes les major général de
la fox polizei c'est à dire la police